we do know that this past year we have
basically had more broader Crossings
than at any point going forward there
was that orange man years ago who kept
saying let's build a wall and you don't
have a country if you don't have a
border everyone called him racist now we
just have people rampaging over the
Border uh Karen Jean-Pierre was asked
about that situation and there's
estimates of 50 000 migrants in Mexico
waiting to cross at title 42 M's is that
accurate and would that overwhelm the
border patrol so look I don't don't have
a a number for you at this time what I
can say is that we know smuggers will
try to spread misinformation to take
advantage of these vulnerable migrants
but I want to be very clear here the
fact is that the removal of title 42
does not mean the border is open anyone
who suggests otherwise is simply doing
the work of these Smugglers who again
are spreading misinformation and which
are which is very dangerous when title
42 goes away as we are uh as we have to
do because of a court order which is on
on Wednesday as all of you know we will
go back to title 8 which allows a
process to make sure that people can
make their Asylum claims her okay rather
extraordinary lady the border is not
open the border is not open and it's
only Smugglers that are getting these
people across these migrants you know
she keeps using the phrase migrants
because migrants somehow implies that
they're just coming here for work and
they're okay people we don't know what
these people are we have no idea what
their beliefs are we also have enough
problems in our country that I'm pretty
sure we could close our border and take
a week to figure out some stuff and then
we could talk about it but what are you
saying lady it's just these Smugglers
that are bringing all these people
across well hot diggity dog here's video
from this weekend
do you need
it
thank you
okay
as you can see there by the last video
we've hired the Predator to guard the
Border that's what we're at we're up
against at this point the Predator using
heat technology is defending the Border
he had to be privately contracted
because the government won't do it but
does any of that look like these are
Smugglers that these people are being
smuggled in there's no way to figure out
what's going on here literally lines of
hundreds of thousands of people just
kind of wandering on through all good
you don't even have to walk like this
you could just kind of wander in it's
all good right there's no problem here
absolutely crazy the the portion of that
video where it was a bunch of people
sleeping on the floor that is the El
Paso Airport that was yesterday now
what's fascinating about this is it
seems like there were dozens if not
hundreds of people there remember when
what was it how many people was it 25
people was it 50 people let's say 100
people went to Martha's Vineyard
remember when they bust them up to
Martha's Vineyard Rhonda said just bust
them over to Martha the media went
bananas for five days it's going to
overtake the island there are no
Services Martha's Vineyard one of the
richest places in all of the United
States Barack Obama has a 30 acre
mansion on the water there he could have
put a couple tents up but I guess maybe
he was busy or just didn't pick up the
phone